[Music]  [Music]  looking for you  what are we what if I told you there's a  place where people have powers like us  city of Adeline and I can take you there  we're Inhumans  [Music]  maybe I'm foolish maybe I'm blind and  you na can see through this love behind  brother sooner or later the humans are  going to find got no way to prove it so  maybe I'm not the first course of action  will be to try to destroy one  I'm only human after all we need to go  to earth now we need to strike first it  would only lead to war are you speaking  for yourself or for our King  [Music]  Maximus is trying to take over aniline  are you going to kill your only brother  Yii I'm only human after honor me  imagine you came after all don't put the  blame on me don't put your blame on me  you're just a shaman